[Music]
on today's show we talked to a man who's
heartbroken because his buddy took his
own life
we talked to a new wife who's trying to
set boundaries with her parents
we talked to a mom of two young kids
who's trying to separate loving them and
jealousy among siblings stay tuned
[Music]
what up what up this is john with the dr
john delonay show
a show
for you about you by you it's a
caller-driven show where we talk about
real challenges in real people's lives
folks i've never met before who are
calling from all over planet earth to uh
check in and walk alongside me and me
walk alongside you as we try to figure
out what's going on with our mental
health our relationships and schools and
parenting grief all of it right all of
it so
so glad you joined us there's about 11
billion podcasts and you picked this one
so i'm so grateful for you for those of
you who are listening to this at one and
a half speed or two speed
i recognize i talk fast so my buddy of
mine was like man you talk so fast and
then i asked him if he was watching it
at 1x or i mean at one and a half for 2x
speed and he's like oh yeah you talk
fast regularly so you may want to put
this one back on one speed and then it
will feel like it's 2x because i talk
real fast but we're so glad you're here
it's good to see everybody in the booth
oh my goodness one of my favorite people
on planet earth walking in front of the
booth right now makes my heart feel good
hey kelly james listen
last night i got home me and james
i think it's time to break into the
world we're in a pretty awesome metal
band
and um i don't really know how to say
we're taking over
earth but we are and after our practice
last night they went into the wee hours
of the morning and by wee hours in the
morning i mean like 7 30. um
it was it was nighttime right we went
outside and we watched the sunset just
as the as a band
james put his shirt back on and um
changed out of his leather pants and
just like into jeans
and uh covered up some of his tattoos
and then we we
i went home and i got out of the car out
of my truck and my daughter was
weeping
and that could be any number of things
and i said what's wrong
oh no
my wife had planned this um
olympic watch event with the kids and so
they went upstairs
oh and the chicken doors didn't close
all the way and my two dogs
oh man it was not great it's not great
my son man it was devastating he we got
these things as chicks as like little
bitty peep peeps and they it's been nine
months now and like this is the their
egg egg-laying month every day twice a
day feeding them training them
oh man
was it are they all gone no
several
man and then it's my dogs and they are
great and but they come up to you like
they've just helped out
and that didn't end well i mean oh geez
louise and i just get out of the car and
it's crying and tears and heartbreak and
then i got sad and i'm kind of a
side hustle prepper and i'd kind of
planned on you know if it all goes down
we got eggs and now we don't
we'll have egg
anyway
i put out a call let's see if we can get
some more chickens but it was a
heartbreak night for our family
that's rough man what do you do as a
former chicken
owner
yeah ours was a different kind of trauma
because i had to cull several of our
chickens
you're the murderer yep wow you had to
call that's such a uh i know distancing
scientific word for whoa i didn't know i
was i was googling like how to um
handle chickens at the end of their life
and realize there's this fancy you know
whitewashed term for it and
it's like when people uh go hunting and
they harvest
uh that's i don't know this is why i buy
my eggs in the store like a normal human
i don't have to deal with this
wow
hmm
we'll see when it all goes down who's
knocking on whose door right actually
i'll probably knock on your door because
because the infiltrator yeah you don't
have any eggs what are you gonna do with
the turtles or just walk right past
kelly's house they'll be like all right
let's go to this and then the the
general will be like now we want to skip
that house we're good we'll go to the
next one so it's good
all right so we're we're working through
it all right let's go to uh rich in
chicago hey rich what's up man
hey dr d what's going on we're man we're
getting through dude how about you man
i'm just gonna say that uh eggs at the
store about a dollar a dozen i'm just
saying
i know but if i raise the chickens
myself they're about 111 dollars a dozen
right
yeah if you start doing the math on that
stuff it does not work out in the
preposition
so it's ridiculous
but it is cool and it's also i gotta
walk through grief with my son and
anyway so it is what it is man how about
you brother how can i help man
well um i get a little brief history um
i'm an alcoholic i've been in recovery
now for
for quite a while i've been in recovery
since 2007 um working a 12-step program
uh part of
what we do in the program is it's one
alcoholic working with another
that seems to work where other things
fail and so we we call it sponsorship
and it's um
it's kind of an integral part of
both sides my recovery and the guys that
i sponsor and
i have a sponsor and i have a grand
sponsor and it just goes on and on um so
we've kind of built up this community
paul you've been sober
i've been sober uh just under 14 years
be 14 years into the month if
if i survive yeah can we congratulate
you man can i just stop and say i'm
proud of you
thank you that's that's tough man that's
a long ride congratulations man uh
i burned down uh
burned down our uh
our finances in our relationship uh 14
years ago and
said no more huh
stood there in the ashes and my wife
took my hand we looked at each other's
eyes and said we're gonna be okay and uh
started that process and uh
it's uh so far so good so far so good
brother um
to call you a hero would be undermining
the mission you and work you've done and
your wife too and so congratulations to
you man
all right
he brought
he brought me to god and god brought me
to aaa and that's just kind of what it
looks like it's awesome so good for you
brother
all right so i interrupted you yes so
we're you got to sponsor a grand sponsor
you're sponsoring
and
what brought you here today man
well um
a guy came into the program about 10
years ago
um saw him struggling he'd go uh two
years sober relapse two years over
relapse
about four years ago he approached me
and wanted me to to help him and so i
began sponsoring him and if you're
familiar with the steps we go through a
process where
they they pretty much dump everything on
us i mean they they go through a process
of inventory and and uh they lay it all
out on the table and we go through it
with them and
so basically i know more about the guy
than than anybody on the planet by the
time we're through with that process if
he works it the way he's supposed to and
this guy this guy did i'm pretty
confident he did yeah
um
about three weeks ago this guy took his
own life ah man i'm sorry dude damn dude
and uh
well it's just got you know it's
obviously knocked the wind out of my
sails i mean i've got a good community
around me i got good friends in and out
of the program
you know we're working through it it's
still raw it's three weeks out but uh
and i get that part you know and i also
get the part where
i don't have any control over the guy i
don't have any control over what's in
his head and any of that stuff
he uh
the way we worked what worked for him
um
we communicated daily
so we were tight i mean we were pretty
close
and
so
we communicated on a wednesday
um
he didn't call thursday didn't call
friday and i got a phone call from his
daughter saturday morning
no no no outside indicators nothing
that was obvious to anybody now i know
that he did suffer from depression he
did have some anxiety issues and i know
he was seeing a professional about that
he was working on a program outside of
ours obviously
this is going to sound um go ahead go
ahead
no no i'm sorry no you go ahead go ahead
um
so what i'm dealing with now
is
what am i doing
yeah this this whole sponsorship thing
it's got me
it's i'm back on my heels here i
i just
i i i
kind of shudder at the thought of
picking up another sponsor i mean i'm
not a i'm not a psychologist i'm not a
professional i i don't you know we don't
deal with mental health issues
i'm just a drunk trying to help another
drunk
and
when i'm faced with
this kind of thing you know and like my
grand sponsor took me aside and and we
were at the visitation and
he said you can't take this personal
and i i get the sentiment
but
it's flipping personal
yeah it's real personal man
real personal
so your sponsor is trying to love you
the best you can and
um
this is personal and trying not to take
it personal is insane
okay this is personal as it gets i want
you to take this person i want you to
let it sit in your heart this this hurts
okay
um
and first and foremost dude um there's
i'm sorry i i've been there i've done
too many memorial services for people i
love um and upset i'm sorry
um
have you wept yet have you sat in this
yet
oh yeah okay all right good oh yeah
i uh
his daughter asked me to do the eulogy
at the funeral and and
you know when i went through that
process it was it was it was pretty
cathartic for me i mean it was
it was cleansing for me i was able to
get past a lot of stuff just by writing
that thing yeah and getting up in front
of the crowd and and saying it out loud
that
that helped me a lot um
and like i said i've got i've got
super close friends in and out of the
program i've got a couple of buddies
that
by calling my 2 am friends they're the
guys that you call them no matter what
time of night and they're in your
driveway that's right that's right
um
i've talked through all this with with
those guys
obviously through the community in the
program
um lots of support there
yeah but i think i think i'm good yeah
um
but there's that there's that underlying
kind of guilt thing yeah there you go um
i've gone through the the whole grieving
situation you know where i was sad and i
was upset and i was and then i got angry
you know why the hell didn't he call me
um that kind of thing
yeah now you're in that futile wasteland
yeah you're back in ash and you've been
in ashes before right yeah yeah
so there's a difference between
not taking this personal which you
should
and blaming yourself
and those are two vastly different
feelings and processes
okay
there's no way in three weeks you've
cycled through everything you'll be
cycling through stuff for a long time
okay and they'll cycle quick you'll be
pissed off then you'll cry and then
you'll miss him and then you'll be
laughing
and so think of it as tight circles and
the circles get bigger and they get
bigger and you'll go through a longer
season where you're raged out against
this guy
because he's going to screw up your
weekends he's going to script like
there's a you know i mean it's hard you
get pissed off at him even though you
know it's stupid to get pissed off at
him and that he was hurting and and anne
um and then you will have this just
scorched earth where you feel like
you're walking on in a desert with no
trees no water no nothing
and you'll loop back and you'll look
back but
the difference between taking it
personal being heartbroken and blaming
yourself those are different do you get
the difference of those
i think that's probably the problem i'm
having is they're kind of overlapping
okay all right
they're kind of infringing on each other
and i think that's
that's kind of what i'm dealing with is
i so a lot of times when you especially
when you work a process when you work a
program there's a there's a reason
behind every feeling every feeling is
connected to a thought and every thought
is connected to an action does that make
sense
that's that's the beauty of the steps
where this gets out of whack is in the
depth of grief
external grief right so they give you
the 12 steps so that this thing never
happens again
and the challenge to that is
underneath you things happen right and
so the steps give you a level of control
that a drunk or a drug addict or a sex
addict don't normally have or a food
addict or whatever it gives them control
over them
where it's challenged it can feel like
it's a whole thing's unwound like you're
experiencing right now when a meteorite
hits you and that's what happened
because you can't control for that right
and so it makes you think well why am i
even doing these steps these are stupid
they're dumb they don't even protect me
from filling the blank
and
the hard part is hanging on to what you
know works
and at the same time going uh this
happened right that's the difference
between blame and so the steps work man
they've you're sober for 14 years um and
the past has
given you relationships 2 a.m friends
it's given you a model for what
friendship looks like and connection
looks like and my guess is you're a
better husband and a better dad a better
community member and all those things
and this just hurts
they're both and and sometimes step
programs don't do both and very well it
does either or really well
right
and so it's being able to sit and say
this hurts
and not my fault
i was this guy's go-to and
he did this
and not linking the two things together
and it's hard and this is where
journaling is really important because
you can separate those two this is when
writing him letters writing yourself
letters
in
too rich dear rich not i i but dear rich
this happened and i'm sorry how would
you talk to somebody who called you how
would you call to another sponsor who
had their own sponsor how would you be
coaching them right now
you'd be saying brother it's not your
fault
all right this hurts and that's i'm
gonna hug you and we're gonna go hang
out we're gonna go the batting cages or
whatever
but you didn't do this
right and so that's that hard balance
that hard gap
um real quick
and i know this is gonna sound
gratuitous and it's not how did he take
his life
uh he used a gun okay was he intoxicated
yes okay
um do you remember back when you were
drunk and you did dumb things you did
things that you normally you look back
and go
whoa you remember those times
oh yeah
of course yeah and so what i want you to
do like you spent 14 years learning how
to forgive yourself right and how to be
graceful to yourself
eventually
you're going to come to look at this man
that you loved and that you considered a
brother probably closer than your real
brother if you have one no who
was connected to other people but could
never overcome that loneliness that
addicts experience
could never get that failure to belong
and then worse
he thought for whatever reason
especially when he was drunk or
especially when he was low that he was
going to be a burden to you
and he didn't call right
right
and
i would say that's a choice he made it
man he was intoxicated he died by
suicide man suicide took a soul from him
and so all that to say at some point
you'll forgive him you'll make peace
with him and
this will in time make you a
not only world class it will make you a
gift of a sponsor to everybody around
you
because now i've sat through so many of
these things i'll look people in the eye
and smile and say i'm not letting this
happen to you i'll call in the calvary
on you i'll call does that make sense
it's made me
better at being a neighbor having gone
through these things i wouldn't do it
again over in a million years
but over time you end up making meaning
out of these things but that's not for
right now right now it's just for saying
sucks
does that make sense
yeah it does it does um
you know i think it i i i can tell
myself
this when i can listen to my sponsors
and i can listen to people in the
program and that's it's all good and i
get it i i totally get it and everything
that you said i get it it's not about
getting it it's not about getting it
it's about sitting in it
the getting it part is don't go drink
the getting it part is don't throw
everything away
because this happened
that happening doesn't mean that the
last 15 years of your life have been a
lie
this mean this what happened meant that
somebody wasn't well and they died by
suicide
you didn't fail brother
you didn't screw up
it's it's it's
it's hard not to tell myself that i know
dude i understand i know it is um
and you're in the middle of it okay
you're in the middle of it
it's
you're you're
you have little kids you have kids
i do okay
think back to the first time you took
one of your kids to the pool and they're
on a diving board and you're waiting
you're treading water out there trying
to get them to jump and they're on the
edge of that diving board and they're
getting closer and closer but they just
won't go and they bend their knees and
they lean over but they don't jump they
don't jump
and then finally they jump
and then they're in that air and it
feels like a hundred years they're in
that air where they're falling and
falling and falling and finally they hit
the water and the dad's there to get
them
you just jumped
you're in the air and people can tell
you hey there's somebody at the bot it
doesn't none of that matters because
you're falling okay
what i'll tell you is you're surrounded
by people who love you
who are there in the water to catch you
when you hit
this is not your fault man
and you can tell yourself that all day
great
i want you to get it out of your head
and once you start writing it down
okay i want you to spend some time
writing it down i want you to journal
about it and i want you to write letters
to two people two rich
into your old friend
okay
and in those letters i want you to be
honest with rich i want you to be honest
with us with um your friend
and
be heartbroken be pissed off be angry
and exhale and get up and go again don't
throw this all away because of that
got it
we same team on that one
yeah i can do that i got your word
you're gonna stay sober
oh yeah okay
oh yeah you're in this for the long haul
brother we're in this with you you
you're doing everything right just
you're falling just suck
okay
i've been there been there been there
i'm having to take a deep breath too man
you'll hit the water and you're safe you
got people around you hang in there hang
in there this is not your fault brother
let's take a quick break right here on
the doctor john lauren show
hey what's up i want to take a quick
break to talk about the most important
question i'm asked almost every day how
do i find a counselor if you can't find
a counselor in your area or you can't
afford one i've got a solution for you
i've partnered with a better help for
customized online therapy video chat
text chat phone counseling it's a
licensed therapist whenever and wherever
you
need them go to betterhelp.com slash
deloney for 10 off your first month it's
cheaper and it's available all the time
this is for you your family and for
everyone else that's coming your way
take care of your mental health go to
betterhelp.com today
all right we're back let's go to anna in
oklahoma city hey anna what's going on
hi hi dr dawn thank you so much for
taking my call of course thank you for
calling how in the world are you i'm
i've had better days uh oh that's an old
uh 90s like pop rock song so let's hear
what's going on
well my husband and i are newlyweds and
we need help setting boundaries with my
parents oh sweet how long have you been
married
well we've only been married for about
four months now okay how's the first
four months going just y'all too
uh well great marriage is good with him
um
[Laughter]
falling deeper in love every day
hey i think after four months my wife
was like oh geez
so good for you anna all right so what's
up how can i help you got a uh you got
parent boundary issues yes yes tell me
about it what are your parents doing
this ought to be great oh man well just
to kind of give you context my parents
are very protective overly protective
and um just more over the years i've
seen how controlling they are
um
so when i was 18 years old i moved out
of my parents house and just got caught
up in the party lifestyle and
and drugs and so my parents saw that um
you know along the way and i did that
for about eight years of my life and my
parents you know how to
i mean that was just hard for them to to
see that um over the years um
but anyway along the way around
25 years old i just kind of
came to the end of myself and met the
lord and decided to you know turn my
life around went to school got a degree
and match for my bachelor's in biblical
counseling
and started working with women
at a drug rehab
so i've been doing that for years and
then met my husband along the way how
old are you
i am 33. wow okay fantastic 23.
yeah so i met my husband along the way
and you know a long you know these years
i haven't really dated
um
just because i hadn't met the right one
and so when i met my husband i just we
knew we just we knew that we were
supposed to be together gross and
close
i'm sorry
all right
so anyway i you know
once that happened i think my parents
expectations of how that was supposed to
look
um they wanted me to
to date for you know a couple of years i
guess before marrying him
so
you know i talked to my parents i said
hey you know this man i know he's
supposed to be the one you know and so
they jumped on the bandwagon
and so
leading up to just planning the wedding
um
i had a discussion with my mom
about
just the finances and i said you know my
husband and i we're gonna pay for it you
guys don't have to worry or feel the
pressure about you know with the with
the wedding
um however
my mom had said you know what we're
gonna go ahead and pay for it we're
gonna bless you guys
so with that being said uh
three weeks before our wedding
uh my mom said we're just gonna pay for
the cake
so i'm thinking are you kidding me
and i and she's like yes we're just
gonna pay for the cake why'd she back
out and change your mind
yeah well when i asked her about it she
said well you misunderstood oh sweet and
i'm like are you i said mom i said this
is not about misunderstanding i said you
gave me your words i'm so happy
i'm not really happy
okay so so they gave you they just paid
for the cake and then by the time it
rolled around they paid for the straws
and the salt and pepper shakers and then
yeah then okay so you get you get
married and it's four months down the
road and
you're falling deeper in love every day
what are they
what are they doing how are they trying
to um exert control over you still
well so
well my parents
they
keep saying they don't know my husband
and they keep
so
just to back up my husband i tried to
set boundaries we met with them putting
them or making a bullet list of just
letters
um
or a letter of bullet points of things
that needed to be dressed
and so they shared it with the whole
family the letter that we had asked them
to keep confidential between all four of
us
what was in this in this letter
um so it was just boundaries basically
you know be kind and
um also we just said
we expect honesty
and we just shared our hearts and my
husband and i we just we sat down with
them we met with them because i'm from
the dallas fort worth area and now i
live in in oklahoma so we drove out
there just to talk to talk to them
and share our hearts with them about
everything that had happened leading up
to the wedding are they not are they
generally not kind are they i mean were
you addressing things that you had seen
or were you just
stating things okay okay so the things
in your letter the bullet points were
things
were behaviors and interactions and
relationships you guys had experienced
already yeah and so i mean even when
we're yes to get your relationships off
and again you're not 18 you're 33 for
crying out loud right you've got your
own job he's got his own job y'all are
y'all experienced things and then you
said hey this is how we're gonna go and
get this off on the right foot
and you all buried your soul
and they went and told everybody
yeah well they said that they considered
it a threat
and um
it was just it was unbelievable and i'm
thinking
okay
why did you guys even tell all my
brothers you know so now it's like
they they so now my brother called me
cussed me out for about 30 minutes and
said
you know you need to fix this you need
that you've betrayed the family
and so my mom called me and she said
anna you need to
come up to you know first go and talk to
the whole family without your husband
and i'm like sorry so here here's the
deal here's the deal
yes
you moved out at 18.
yes
for a reason
yeah and
yes you did whatever you act like an 18
year old right and you acted like a 19
year old and a 20 year old here's my
guess my guess is this type of
um pitting brothers against sisters and
this type of
lack of trust and this type of
immaturity and acting like a middle
school
with a with a power ego power trip has
been happening your whole life
and at 18 you went and searched for some
sort of connection
and sleeping with people and alcohol and
drugs
are
chemically very similar to deep
connected relationships they're shorter
and they don't last as long and they
come with a ton of repercussions
yeah but they make sense okay yeah and
there's a reason why
college populations when you take a kid
who's been living at home even in a
messed up home and you pluck them from
everything they know and you send them
across the country and you drop them in
a box with a bunch of other 18 year olds
yeah that alcohol and
and sleeping with somebody
dude it just it makes you go
for a minute and then you gotta go do it
again the next day and do it again the
next day but you're you have young
brains screaming for a connection and
you didn't have that growing up you were
raised by children
and
now you're 33 right there's 10 11 12
years later
you circled back to include them
and once again
they haven't changed they're the same
people and this is the heartbreak for
you and i'll i'll lay it out
systematically okay i'm gonna be honest
with you cool cool great good grand okay
and um
you've grown up a lot
you saw the world a lot
right you've got experiences a lot and
here's the thing when you think back
between on your 18 to 25 times you did
stuff that you regret but you also
learned a lot and yeah i bet you met
some extraordinary people right yeah and
i bet you are more compassionate than
most of the people in your life right
yes
and you also realized ah there's a
there's just a more peaceful better way
to live right and so you've done hard
hard work on anna
and now you know what grace in a
relationship looks like and strength and
boundaries and connection and being
vulnerable you know what those things
are and you met a guy
who you're going deeper in love with
everyday who shares that with you right
and by the way you know i'm joking here
right i'm like making faces you know i'm
kidding
i'm really excited for you
so here's the gonna be
the hardest thing you've ever done
yes it's gonna be killing that fantasy
that you can loot back and have it all
the way you wanted it to be
yeah
because what you're trying to do is
collapse the last however many years
and make it to where you're 25 and
you're getting married again and mom and
dad are involved in the wedding and your
brothers and your new husband all hang
out and go hunting together and they
play golf together and they whatever and
that's not going to happen
yeah
i'm sorry
yeah because your parents are children
maybe your brothers have grown up
maybe your brothers are a little bit
different and mom and dad put them in an
unfair position to choose between them
and you
which really stinks right
and maybe go and have a drink with your
brother gonna have some coffee with your
brother one one-on-one and saying hey
here's what we're doing man
and they know your mom and dad too
they know yeah right and they're either
reproducing that behavior in their
little families or they've grown up and
it's different and they got put in an
unfair position right is what it is
but at the end of the day you set up
your boundaries
and said here's what we expect we expect
people to be kind to each other to not
lie to us
um we want to have fun safe
laughter joy-filled holidays together we
want to come down to dallas but it's
like a five-hour drive we're gonna come
down to dallas and hang out with y'all
on the weekends but
here's the things and your parents
spit on your boundaries man
and that's what they're for
right to either be honored or set on
fire
and your parents pissed on yours and so
now you got the you got the message
right you got yours yeah
and i hate that for you so here's what
you got to do
you're going to have to be highly
intentional arou about being around
adult couples who are older than you and
wiser than you
and forming some sort of surrogate
relationships with couples who are 10
years down the road
who you and your husband will go hang
out with have coffee with
go i don't know whatever you do in
oklahoma i just feel like oklahoma's a
state of sadness and so i don't know
i'm just kidding it's a great place to
live all texans are raised to think like
if you go to oklahoma it all ends right
but i understand what you're doing and
you're proselytizing so you're you're
spreading the will of texas up into the
north and i appreciate that but you're
gonna have to find some families um who
are going to be the grown up
wise people who love you and love your
husband and invest in y'all that your
parents should be but are not
but aren't
if i'm you i would reach out to my
brothers one on one and by the way two
important things nobody cusses me out
for 30 minutes
they cuss me out for one second because
then i hang up the phone not gonna hear
that not gonna listen to that
at all
and i'll tell another grown-up when
you're ready to talk like a grown-up
we'll have a conversation but i'm out
and then maybe a week later two weeks
later for somebody i love i'll reach
back out and say you ready to talk like
a grown-up and if they're not then i'm
i'm not gonna i'm not gonna do that i'm
just not
the challenge for you is and the second
challenge is for you to not give over
your integrity not get over over the
growth you've had to try to
crawl back and
make them okay
i want you and your husband to get the
book um
dad i just i forget the title every time
you know this one james
it's
it's parents it's children of
emotionally adult
adult children of emotionally immature
parents who wrote that book
it's right there
susan gibson is at it
lindsay gibson so
anna i want you to get you and your
husband to get the book adult children
of emotionally immature parents by dr
gibson gibson it's a masterpiece it's
really thin it's wonderful you'll
probably end up highlighting more of the
book than not i want you all to work
through that together
and then i want you to reassess your
boundaries reassess who you all want to
be as a couple where you all going to go
what's the picture of what your marriage
is going to look like and you all live
into that your parents have opted out
and you all have to agree
it's heartbreaking i hate it for you
i hate it for you and hopefully your
brothers won't opt out
nothing was worse than getting burned by
two people who said we're supposed to
love you and by the way
you broke their heart when they're 18 19
20. so it's true
but they have chosen to not grow with
you they've chosen to be frozen
and i'm a rapper now because i just
rhymed chosen and frozen um they've
chosen to remain frozen in their
maturity and their love for you it's
still
it's still got strings it's still not
it's still got like
still keeping you guys off kilter here
you all are 33 you got both feeling
go find a couple today man go find a
couple and reach out and start that
healing process with new people man i'm
so so sorry for you
you always hear me talking about how
good deep sleep impacts your anxiety
your depression your attitude your
mental health your physical health your
work performance sleep is critical to
every single thing in your life and if
you want to change the way you sleep you
first start with a world class mattress
one that you can actually afford and you
know i only recommend things that me and
my family use in our home and that's why
i partnered with dream cloud mattress
dream cloud gives you premium
world-class materials in a mattress at
half the price they utilize innovative
sleep signs to build mattresses that
keep you cool that support you in any
position and it adapts to your body i
made sure they have price points for
every budget dreamcloud is for you they
are currently running their biggest
offer ever a total of 650 bucks in
betting and cash savings exclusive for
dr john dolone's show listeners they
also have a 365 day home trial sleep on
it for a year and if you don't like it
send it back visit
dreamcloudsleep.com get 650 in savings
and goodies and start sleeping today
take one more let's go to emily in
pittsburgh hey emily what's going on
hey how are you dr john we are rocking
onto the break-a-dawn how about you
good i was you know cleaning up toys
while the daniel tiger clean up song
runs through my head to live in a good
life
that is not a good life
that's pretty cool hey so what's up how
can i help
um so
my son is almost two and last month he
was officially diagnosed with
a significant disability okay i also
have
what's this what's the disability
cerebral palsy okay all right
okay um and um i also have a
four-year-old daughter who she's
developing typically she's fine and she
loves her brother to pieces but i have a
a two-part question um
what can i do to protect her from having
like jealousy and trauma associated with
having a sibling with a disability
because like you hear about that
all the time but like i want to know how
to kind of help prevent that and then um
also
how can i
you know give him as much support and
attention and understanding as he needs
with a disability but also prevent
spoiling him you know like giving into
things and letting him get away with
stuff so
like pretty much how do i raise
both my kids without the disability
getting in the way and causing issues
you won't the disability is in the way
and it's caused issues right
um so number one i'm gonna answer the
second part first and then we'll loop
back to the first one okay so the second
part is a
you thing
okay okay
have you exhaled this yet and i'm gonna
say something that i know is unpopular
in bl but it's the truth i've just
worked with too many parents with
children with special needs
have you grieved this
have you just exhaled and been
heartbroken
um
i i don't know if i can officially say
that i have because i'm like i'm very
much in charge of his like organizing
his therapy and making sure so like i
feel like i've been very much
leaning into the practical side of
everything yeah like what can i do what
should i do
and i'm actually looking at
getting a counselor
in the area
just because i've realized this is
probably
more than i can handle myself
i i think you're gonna find yourself
infinitely stronger than you ever
thought
and you again it's going to be
imperative for for you to get a
community of parents in your area that
have children who've had similar
diagnostics or life experiences
and having a community of people you can
text and reach out to all that's
important
but at some point you when you found out
you were pregnant
you had a picture of what this was going
to be like
and the picture is now different
and all i'm asking is yes you're going
to try to solve this for a while you're
going to try to to channel all of that
energy and frustration and heartbreak
and you know his life is going to be
hard
and then you're going to have those oh
my gosh what about
what about if something happens to me
and my husband like what you're gonna
have all those things
right
and
to be able to handle those things so
that your body doesn't take off on you
into anxiety or frustration or those
spinning in the middle of the nights
which i know you've had
there's a moment when you have to just
not a moment there's a season where you
gotta grieve it you thought it was gonna
be like this and it's not
and you wanted your son to grow up and
fill in the blank and he's not it's
gonna be a different experience not that
you hate him not that you don't love him
you're not grateful for all that stuff
but just got to grieve that gap okay
what i'm telling you is cerebral palsy
is something you can run from and solve
for
it's something that you're going to
experience right
and that's a you think so how do you not
give
how do you not um spoil him don't spoil
him
right i know that sounds so easy
um
your identity
your
there's no way for you to make up for
the pain he's experiencing there's no
way for you to make up for
the challenges he's going to have with
ice cream and cookies and staying a
plate and watching and all those things
does that make sense no yeah the
tendency is that you're going to want to
keep your thumb on the other side of
that scale cosmically you're going to
have to let that go he still needs to
sleep and eat healthy and have
boundaries and be respectful to you and
be respectful to his sister and all
those things that make sense
right so it's working within the
parameters of his physical challenge in
his does he have cognitive challenges
too are these mostly physical
no thank goodness it's mostly mostly
gross motor skills okay
excellent so
yeah so he'll know right and what you'll
be able to teach him about living with
his challenges and how he can honor the
people in his world and how he can deal
with evil little kids that are gonna be
mean to him and make fun of him and
those who are going to rally around him
and love him in a way that other kids
will never understand right it's all of
it
um but trying to solve for it or hit the
other end of the cosmic scale is going
to be a futile exercise okay
the second thing here with your
four-year-old
two important things here
number one
you're is
i'm piling it on here and i know
you're gonna have to make special you
and daughter time
whether that's hiring a middle school
kid to come over and just be in the
house with you while you and your
daughter make something or go watch i
don't know what your financial situation
is or if your husband comes and can deal
with it or whatever but having carved
out time whether it's one day a week or
two days a week with a four-year-old or
a little bit of time every day
that they that she just gets you
and this is highly intentional no phone
no anything other than eye contact on
the floor playing creating worlds
lots of touch lots of interaction
but this is letting her know that you
see her does that make sense is there
like is there like a certain amount of
time i know you can't like quantify it
but like we've been trying to do i guess
some people call it puck in time where
like he goes to bed first since he's
younger and then
she gets like 10 to 15 minutes of just
whoever's putting her to bed that night
like of just their time she can choose
whatever we're playing 10 to 15 minutes
probably is not enough
if that's the best if that's the best
you got that's the best you got okay
everyone's got to do what they've got to
do now i know there's a single mom with
three kids right now one of them's got
special needs in five or ten minutes is
two hours of their life because their
work she's working three jobs i get that
10 to 15 minutes if that's what you got
that's what you got
if you've got another partner at home
who's able to do bedtimes on certain
nights and you're able to just have ice
cream night and you know how i am about
sugar take your kid out from ice cream
take your kid out on we go to the park
um from six to eight and we may miss a
family dinner once a week because it's
just us it's special girl time or it's
daddy and daughter time right whatever
that looks like you and your husband are
going to have a season that's going to
be different than folks with
physical or neurotypical kids you're
going to have a couple of years where
you're going to have to split up a
couple of times a week and make sure
there's some highly intentional time
but here's the second part
and i learned this from one of my
professors dr aretha marbley she's one
of those brilliant women i've ever met
and she
helped my family and my kids are are
typical kids
and it has i've given this i've passed
this along to every parent of any type
of kids and it's been magical
and that is beginning to refer to
your son or to your daughter
refer to your little boy as hers
we're going to help out your brother
we're going to go help out your baby
and bring her along for the ride let her
have ownership as the key word
give her a couple of jobs that she can
do that are
um she's able to do like whether it's
physically or cognitively but let her
have ownership of the care
and love of her little brother
and what happens is she will get
frustrated because she's four right
she's not gonna be able to wrap her head
around this stuff and i never get mad at
a four-year-old for being selfish
because that's a four-year-old to do i
don't get mad at seven-year-olds or
eleven-year-olds for being selfish or
frustrated right but i continue to model
it number one number two i keep bringing
them back in i keep bringing them back
into
hey this you're part of the care and
love this is what care and love looks
like in our house
and the trauma part she may ask hard
questions like why him and not me y'all
experience those questions as they go
the trauma is going to be different for
her because this is all she knows
you and her will have different trauma
okay because you know a different
picture she will not this is just what
brothers are it won't be till she goes
to college and learns that oh your
brothers are different or goes to high
school right
um this will be her experience but give
her some jobs some participation some
relational um
uh support that she can provide and give
her ownership and she will grow into
that in a really remarkable way and of
course she's enough temper tantrums of
course she's not gonna want to do it and
blah blah blah that's part of being four
but some very specific time and some um
ownership there and kelly you've got
this experience you have any i do hi
emily i have special i have uh two
special needs kids at home as well um
i'm gonna rebut just a hair of what you
put all of it dude um
with the giving them a job
i see where you're going with that but
it's also super important to make sure
that the typical developing child knows
that this is not their responsibility
correct their participation not their
deal or making sure that your daughter
knows that
your son is i mean she doesn't have to
become the little mama correct she
doesn't have to spend all of her time
and
not do things that she would normally do
you know she still needs to be a kid
so i've recently i was thinking about
that and i wondered um so i've been
trying to phrase when i asked her to
help specifically with something with
ben not necessarily something like
around the house that you know her
responsibility but
um i try to say hey would you like to go
get his toy for him if you don't want
you don't have to
would that be like a good way of
approaching that yeah i mean is it's the
same things you would if he was a
typical developing baby you know a
little a little brother yeah which you
would ask them to help with that
so just making not piling on because
they can't do this so you have to and
there are going to be some things where
you do have to they have to step up you
know with ours or teenagers now and so
which is its own you know monster but
there's things that you know when the
basketball goes rolling down the hill
i'm sorry but your sister can't go get
it she's in a wheelchair go get the yeah
you gotta go get the ball yeah you know
and they don't want to but you make them
because they have to
or no you have to hold the door for her
because she can't get it so there's
things that they have to do but you also
have to let them be a kid as well
going back to something john said about
grieving it that took us years and was
one of the biggest things we did and
real quickly there's a story called the
tulips in holland that it's kind of
passed around special needs families
that
you plan for this trip to italy and you
study italian you know all the places
you're going to go you have your whole
trip planned you have the money that's
you know that you're going to use there
and everything is planned and then you
get off the airplane and you're in
holland
well that's not what you planned you
don't know anything about it you don't
know what you're gonna do you don't know
how to speak the language
but it's pretty
and then
but you have to let go of italy and go
you know what we're gonna stay here
because we're not italy's not an option
now so i have to let go of that but man
aren't the tulips pretty here
so it's the whole idea of you have to
let that go
and that's hard to do because you had
plans and i guarantee your husband had
plans for this little boy yeah
i think i think it's harder on him
because yeah that's his son as much
involved in like the day-to-day like
you know everything else that's going on
he feels like he has very little control
over
what's going on yeah and that's his son
and that's a lot harder but you know now
that just changes and so y'all you
really do have to spend the time um
there was a lot of tears with us and it
took us a long time to do that of man
what are the things that aren't going to
happen that you wish would and we had to
say it to each other i mean this isn't
going to happen you know we're never
going to do this together no but then
later on you figure out no but we will
do this other thing and it's really cool
too
but you have to go don't think that's
selfish you have to do that part that's
right yeah and kelly i love that you
made that great differentiation yeah
this is not
your four-year-old's child to raise
right right it's teaching her hey
let me put this in my house we have
certain chores that the kids do that we
don't give them an allowance for
because there is just a participation
this is just things you do to be a part
of a family
and then if you want to do some extra
jobs that normally mom and dad do or
that i might hire out then i'll pay you
for that right so we're not going to pay
you for taking
um your plate over after dinner or wash
or wiping your stuff into the trash and
putting your dishes in the dishwasher
that's called being a human right
same here but giving i like that the
ownership but not responsibility that's
a great that's a great differentiation
yeah and some other things john you know
that when you asked about um
not spoiling him
and that's hard to do it is because you
want to make up for it i feel bad
whatever
that you know that there this this
happened or whatever but he
he needs to have consequences
um within his physical boundaries of
whatever he whatever he is able to do he
has expectations
just like your daughter has expectations
of what she's supposed to do um and
especially since he is um
you know neurotypical as far as he
doesn't have any delays mentally that
you know he has to be respectful he has
to do his homework when that time comes
he has to do this
and you know these are the tours that he
can do so he is expected to do them
be it house i mean you know sometimes my
daughter picks up sticks out of the yard
whenever after a storm because it's what
she can do
but she's expected to do it she's
expected to do it well
and
so that he and he needs those because
things will be expected of him because
he probably will move into the real
world because he is you know typically
developing mentally and so he'll have to
know how to do those things and it's
just you know when they ask the
questions of why did this happen and
just sometimes we have to go i don't
know but it sucks and i'm so sorry
but we always tell my daughter the only
thing that her wheelchair gets her is
front of the line at disney and better
parking
that's right
and that's it because everything else
you're this is this is how our house
functions and you're a part of that and
you have to do your part i love it love
it love it and emily so here's what i
want you and your husband to do um and
this is not gonna be is me heart okay i
want you all to write a letter
to your 16 year old son and i want you
to read it to each other and in this
letter
i want you to write about the things
you're going to miss
i'd expected that we'd be playing catch
i had in my head this fantasy that we
were going to go play golf together or
whatever the thing is
and i want you to be honest about the
things you're going to miss you might
have art sheila's already planning for
who's going to be sitting around her
table at thanksgiving when
hank and josephine our kids are you know
i mean it's just you go down that rabbit
trail
and then i want you to write about the
things the possibilities but i am
excited about and i want you to read
this letter to each other and this will
start a conversation between you and
your husband like kelly was talking
about this grieving this
oh man we thought this i don't even know
that i thought this i just expected that
and
it's not and you'll start that grieving
process but you'll also start as she
mentioned you'll start noticing
the tulips in holland because that's
where you live now that's where you live
kelly thank you so much for talking
about your situations and
emily thank you so much for that call
for being vulnerable and um
we wish you the absolute
grandest adventures racing two little
ones four and two by themselves
on any given wednesday are
that's a lot
differentiating and supporting a child's
special needs who's two and then a
typical four-year-old that's going to be
a adventure of a lifetime and um thank
you for sharing that with us
all right as we wrap up today's show
man
this is this one is this is one of those
that actually is one of my favorite
songs of all time
love it with all of my heart it's off
the permanent vacation record
the boys in aerosmith stephen tyler and
the gang
in their greatest
slow dance love song of all time
just one word
angel and it goes like this
i'm alone yeah and i don't know if i can
face the night and i'm in tears
and the crying that i do is for you
and i want your love let's break the
wall between us
don't make it tough i'll put away my
pride enough's enough i've suffered
and i've seen the light
seeing the light
i think i nailed that note you're my
angel come and save me tonight you're my
angel come and make it all right
you're my a-a-a-a-j-l
come and save me tonight right here on
the dr john delona's show